we promised that this week we would
spend both of our lessons looking at
uh roots of complex numbers roots plural
because
we don't just say oh there's a single
square root there are two we don't say
there's just a single cube root like the
cube root of one is just one
no there are actually these other two
there are three in total so i want to
remind you about
um and try and put this in uh sort of
theoretical terms here
uh if we were thinking about our roots
of unity which was like we had a look at
on tuesday if you had some omega if you
raise it to
whatever power you like two three four
five whatever you want if you do end up
with one then we know
some things we've established some
properties about the roots
of unity for instance the first root of
unity is the easy one it's always
i think it's always one now i could
write one here
right however one i want us to remember
is we we sort of employed logic here
from exponential form of a complex
number
right so rather than just write one
which is in rectangular form i'm going
to write it in
exponential form it's going to start e
to the power of what
i times zero the argument is zero isn't
it so
you get that and then what we did was we
we had a look at cube roots so i would
then go oh i'm expecting two more
solutions
polynomial degree three three complex
solutions
so then i started to list here right now
if i'm saying to you
oh i don't know what particular route of
unity we're after could be um six or
seven or eight or a hundred or something
like that
i would have to extend this however long
right so i would say the next one would
come from e to the i
two pi and then i would go to the next
one
and then i would just keep going until
i've got n
of them right does that ring a bell now
here's the thing
i would have to say this is w to the n
but i want to
raise both powers to 1 over n that's the
same effect as taking
the nth root so i would do this i would
divide this by n
this by n this by n and then off i go
these are the nth roots of unity
so what i want to do is then take that
idea and see what happens if we have
any complex number right not just one
unity which is sort of special but what
if we had some
arbitrary complex number so the first
thing to say is
if you have some arbitrary complex
number it might not be one unit
away it might not have a modulus of one
so instead of just saying e to the i
zero i'd have to say r to indicate my
modulus could be anything
i mean it might be one but it could be a
half it could be root three
anything you want i've got my e to the i
up here which is always part of
exponential form but if i'm letting this
be
any complex number then it could have
any angle
it might not just start with zero so i'm
going to indicate
that with a theta okay so if we have
this
being true then i can also say just like
in the previous line
i've got all of the other versions of
that complex number right with
non-principal arguments do you remember
that
so let's go ahead and write them in here
i can say it's
r e to the i theta plus 2 pi that would
be the next one around
and then i could go r e to the theta
plus
4 pi that would be the next one around
after that and i could keep going and i
would have
n of them and the process is going to be
the same
right if i take the nth roots of these
numbers then it's the same as raising
both
sides to the power of 1 over n is that
ok
so let's go ahead and write that in and
then we can notice some patterns here
when you raise a number like r the
modulus right a real number
to the power 1 over n that's the same as
taking the
nth root of that number do you agree
okay so we can just do that
with a real number that's fine but then
when we come to these guys we have to
deal with
these uh exponents these indices that we
have so i'm going to raise
e to the power of i theta on
m do you agree with that that's me
dividing by n in the index
and then i just kind of keep going right
i've still got
the nth root of r as my modulus for my
nth root here and then i'm going to
divide this by n
as well so i'm going to go i and then
theta plus 2
pi that's divided by n it starts to get
a bit it's almost
kind of like i'm on autopilot here
because i don't have to think too hard
because exponential form is built to do
this right so i'll just do one more for
good measure to x
um sort of establish the pattern so i've
got e to the i
theta plus 4 pi on n there we go
and then continue going until you have n
of these
now i want to highlight two important
differences um which are really the key
to these nth roots of any complex number
versus our nth roots of
unity okay from our enter to unity line
our second line here right we can say
that all of the roots of unity no matter
what review you're after
second root of unity third fourth a
hundredth they all line the
circumference of the same circle right
which circle is that
it's the unit circle because what's
implied at the front here is a one
so the modulus of is one for all of
these nth roots okay
these guys do not lie on the
circumference of the unit circle at
least probably not
if our modulus is not one right but they
still lie on the circumference of
a circle right what can you tell me
about that circle
where's its center how do i think about
this
all these complex numbers lie on the
circumference of
the circle which has the same center
where's the center
it's still the origin isn't it because
this modulus
is always by definition measured from
zero right
so i'm gonna note that down i sort of
get that from these
moduli over here that these are still on
the circumference of a circle it's just
a circle
on circumference
of now i want to write the equation
of this circle so i'm going to actually
lean forward
with a slight spoiler into next week's
if i want to talk about
what the equation of a circle is you'll
have to write this down you would
normally say in cartesian terms
say for example the unit circle would be
x squared plus y squared equals one
we recognize this we've seen this before
okay now we could write it like this
here but
we have complex number sort of
terminology to help us right
x squared plus y squared i recognize
this the square
root of x squared plus y squared i have
a very simple
term that gives me this if my complex
number is x plus iy
what is the square root of x squared
plus y squared in the context of complex
numbers
it's the modulus isn't it so i can say a
circle
is all of the set of points where their
modulus
is some particular number uh the radius
right in this case would be
it'll be one but in this case over here
we just discovered right our
radius is not just one it'll be the nth
root of
r whatever modules that was okay so i'm
going to write that in here
still on a circle still center at the
origin
but its radius can change that's the
first thing
the second thing is we've got this
spacing right it's the same spacing that
you saw here
um you know from this solution to the
next one
it's going to be 2 pi on n difference
right so for example we looked at the
cube roots of unity
when we went from here to here that
example was two pi on three
right and then you went again another
two pi and three and then if you went a
third two pi on three you would end up
back at the start right because
two point 3 plus 2 pi 3 plus 2 pi on 3
is 2 pi it's a full revolution right so
it brings you back
here because i'm generalizing not saying
this might be necessarily the cube roots
the difference is not 2 pi on 3 but 2 pi
on
n where n can change right two pi on n
that i'm going to call it a spacing
right we noticed this
last time you've got this equal spacing
around the unit circle
i still have this same equal spacing
it's just around a different circle
is that okay so you still got this equal
spacing
but even though the spacing itself
of the arguments is the same two pi n
all the way through
to pi n all the way through the only
subtle distinction is
because you don't have the nice neat
fact that you know where the first root
is every time for the roots of unity the
first root is always going to be one
argument is zero here your argument
doesn't automatically start with zero so
therefore your first solution
won't necessarily be at one right so
therefore even though you still have the
same equal spacing you have to say
but your first solution doesn't start at
zero it can start it
anywhere depending on whatever your
complex number was so i'm going to write
my first in fact i'm going to say rather
than first solution
you need some notation we're going to
use in a second um we're calling all of
our roots z so i'm going to call the
first root
z 1. and if you had like say cube roots
of unity that'd be z1 z2
z3 and that'd just be rather than like
we're just going to run out of greek
letters right
so i'm going to say the first solution
won't have
an argument of zero unless
it's unity right um and the whole point
is that we're looking at nth roots of
any complex number
um our first argument will be theta on
n right so it might be theta on three if
we were looking at cube roots or theta
one four
if we were looking at fourth roots okay
all right so here is all the theory you
can see we're building on roots of unity
but we've got these two distinctions
right
different circumference still circle
different circumference um still equal
spacing but
you might have to start somewhere else
not just zero okay